nous avons reçu une question de pierre à
propos de la rareté de main-d'oeuvre
pourquoi en sommes-nous rendus là nous
demande-t-il
comment se fait-il que cette rareté
cette pénurie de main d'oeuvre n'a pas
été prévue d'abord faut dire que ça fait
des décennies qu'on évalue quand même au
québec les effets à venir du
vieillissement de la population on dit
qu'on a un vieillissement
parce que la génération des baby boomers
et très peuplée et arrivent à la
retraite presque tout le tout le monde
en même temps finalement
et comparativement à d'autres sociétés
dans le monde la part des 65 ans et plus
augmente rapidement
présentement au québec donc on a des
économistes des démographes l'institut
de la statistique qui ont projeté est
projeté depuis longtemps le passage des
baby boomers à la retraite ils ont
mesuré l'impact théorique sur l'économie
est aussi que la croissance économique
va ralentir parce qu'on aura de plus en
plus de gens à la retraite
pendant que la croissance de la
population active les gens qui
travaillent ou qui recherchent un emploi
7 300 cela va ralentir voire s'arrêter
donc plus de retraités moins 300 chez
les travailleurs ça resserre le bassin
de main-d'oeuvre et en plus nous sommes
présentement dans une croissance
économique qui plus forte depuis la fin
de 2016 donc il s'est quand même créé
beaucoup d'emplois et c'est venu
amplifier ce problème de rareté de
main-d'oeuvre
mais une chose qui est claire les
gouvernements tendent à repousser à plus
tard certaines décisions fondamentales
comme celle de trouver des solutions à
long terme pour atténuer le
vieillissement de la population les
ajustements dans les compétences les
automatisations la productivité
l'immigration le maintien au travail des
travailleurs expérimentés toutes les
solutions sont connues mais on n'a pas
adopté de mesures très fortes pour faire
face à ce problème qu'on voyait pourtant
venir
voilà j'espère que ça répond à votre
question si vous avez d'autres questions
sur les élections vous pouvez nous
écrire à vos élections à commercial
radio canada.ca